Denzel how are you this morning I'm
great how are you I'm doing all right um
do you want to go movies or sports to
start with all right let's go sports
don't talk about the Cowboys how do you
feel today about your cowboy we're
building it's a rebuilding year it's
we're getting better it's not supposed
to be this was supposed to be a Super
Bowl year dogstars but it's not - it's
not over but and it hurts even worse
when the Eagles beat you it is what it
is
when did you start when did you fall in
love with the Cowboys I played for the
the Red Raiders in the before the Boys
and Girls Club was called a boys club
and we used to shift and we would shift
like the old Cowboys remember they would
rage oh you don't know you know you
remember that raise up and then come
back down yeah so we would shift like
the Cowboys so I started watching the
Cowboys and we were the Red Raiders and
Texas Tech were the Red Raiders in in
college so I always started like I
wanted to go to Texas Tech and I wanted
to play for the Cowboys I forget now Tom
Landry started that but the offensive
linemen would go up and then back down
they would go up and back down that's
right and who was the quarterback was
was Staubach there or was it Craig
Morton or Danny white Starbuck yeah all
of them yeah Danny white Starbuck and
who jealous you mentioned uh let's see
Danny when Craig Morton was in there
Greg Morton at one point but Starbuck
was yeah to start with Bob Hayes oh yeah
that that was when you had real speed
they brought in Olympic speed there and
pumping speed Bob Hayes that's right
yeah your favorite basketball team of
all time
now will Wayman so that sounds like
you're a Knick fan but you're a Laker
fan now I'm there you did now you
you got it but but okay so your all time
in the wheelhouse that when you would
have fallen in love with the Knicks the
early 70s you had Clyde and Earl I mean
that was a great team Bill Bradley yeah
but but but but who was who was what was
my man the left-handed shooter that had
the funky shot dick Barnett dick Barnett
I'm talking about butch coal mines and
Barnett would it dick Barnett used to
say fall back baby I think when he would
shoot his jumper is that right did you
get into the garden at all could you get
tickets back then I couldn't afford
tickets but you know we try to find a
way to get in that's all I'm gonna say
okay now assess your game your hoop game
at Fordham get at your peak who plays in
the NBA now the way you played when you
were at Fordham oh boy I had no left
hand so that means nobody but I had
speed you know I grew up in Mount Vernon
with a lot of fast players like like Gus
Williams was was that he was in class
ahead of me but Ray Williams his brother
who played for the next was we were in
the same class he was in my class
all right so nobody now because one is
good now I don't know who's a speed guy
now can you were you a shooter
or were you gunner no I had what you
call a New York game I was a slasher and
could and couldn't shoot so you might
have been I was fast and I had good
defense may be late for PJ Carlesimo
yeah I know PJ yeah freshman year at
Fordham we played played freshman ball
under under PJ I may be a patrick
beverley who's a pesky okay defense yeah
I like Patrick Beverley he's a pain in
the neck and I love that is your what he
knows it you've let him know no I mean
he knows it he told me bothers people
and he can he gets the people was your
shot better than levar Alonzo ball shot
I had about a half Alonso I didn't go
all the way to the hip but I had a
little sideways funky I had a little
Jamal Wilkes going oh I like so excuse
me even before Jamal had Keith wilt oh
doing the UCLA to bring it over their
head sideways corkscrew hope it gets
there when did you fall in love with the
Lakers well you know what I Robert
Townsend after Robert Townsend and I got
what he called scalped tickets and we
got into the game where where it was it
was Boston and the Lakers and who-who
clothes line worthy Macca's McHale
clothes line worthy and they got up and
started fighting and we we got season
tickets now he cried totally clothes
line no glamorous Rambis I think you
know clothesline Lambeth yeah that's
right he clothesline Rambis and I was at
that game and and I had season take I
signed up for it in those days it was
old form so it was called Senate seats I
signed up for some Senate seats me and
Robert Townsend we and I've had I've had
season seats ever since Robert did
Hollywood shuffle Hollywood shuffle
that's right and you were in mighty
Quinn with him weren't you that's right
that's right that's right
wait we wondered this the last time you
stopped and watched a movie when let's
say you're at home and it comes on
you're all by yourselves and nobody's
gonna know your wife's not gonna get any
movie any of your movies when's the last
time I'm okay yeah last time that how
man I haven't watched he I might watch a
scene but from beginning to end
mm-hm I don't watch him are you too
critical no no I don't
I sort of once they belong to the people
once they belong to the people they
belong to the people so I'm sort of done
with it I'm like I'm onto the what I'm
working on people ask me what's your
favorite movie I always say my next one
yeah
because it's the process for me it's
like you know no point we live in this
the last game now the movie is Roman J
Israel Esquire but you often portray
real people and I don't know if that's
by design but this isn't based on a real
person Roman and you know it's funny
because doing a lot of interviews people
think it is yeah I don't know why they
do but but I think it is a real person
it is so specific now I really thought
it was dr. Cornel West you know that the
way you looked there but you know it's
[Laughter]
[Music]
beyond us with you that was a little bit
of my inspiration okay alright so you
you caught something there but there's I
mean there's a lot of ticks in here like
you know this is a quirky guy with
Asperger's exactly okay so how do you
come up with the character or add to
that character like how its presented
and then now what do you do when they
give it to you well you start asking
questions like you read the script and
it'll give you certain answers but it'll
give you questions like well why is he
alone why does he live alone why has he
why did his boss not let him do any
other cases in the court you know you
just start asking wise and you start
answering those questions and you know
why does he why do people talk about his
clothes why does he always wear the same
thing you know things like that and he
started he started finding the character
you start answering those questions
he's idealistic though as a defense
attorney but then all of a sudden what
they tell ya then then there's a series
events that all of a sudden changes
things and then Colin Farrell comes in
yeah at the right time how is that have
you guys worked before
no we haven't really lovely man and
obviously a great actor but but equally
lovely human being and we just had a
good time work on Colin and and just
easy to work with and knows what he's
doing
we had Spike Lee on year ago and I said
sequel to he got game and he said if
you're in he
soon know so he write them he said he
would work on it but he said he needed
you to greenlight it and then he would
write something he used to have game we
call it I'd be coaching now yes I can
get Ray Allen Ray's God time you read
got time it's ray done he raised done
done is he playing anywhere I can still
shoot I think he's done done he can
always shoot man that guy can I used to
feed him feed him the ball he'd go
around a three-point line just bang bang
bang bang there there's a poetry true to
it though like that rhythm that they
have and I think he's got you know you
know if we rank greatest shooters ever I
put him in the top five form
he talked everything form he talked
about staying in the in the in the what
he call in the phone booth not slide and
not jumping up and slide in one way or
the other he go straight up textbook and
yours was like that no no I was I was no
no it was here's what textbook well good
luck with the movie it's always great to
talk to you how much and there's a and
you know more importantly it's great
talking sports with you I mean you're
probably gonna go through this carwash
talking about this movie when you know
I'd rather talk about Jamal Wilkes or
something like that
the movie will Keith Wilkes
Jamal Wilkes yeah well that was when he
was at UCLA with Bill Walton no no no
that's when when silk Wilkes was there
he was key oh yeah oh yeah all right but
who else was on that team so it was wilt
Walton Keith Lee was the point guard
they had good rig no Goodrich was in the
60s with Walt Hazzard that was their
John Wooden first national title team
Walton had Larry Holyfield and Larry for
real Larry Larry Palmer yeah no actually
I'm kidding
named I'm sitting next to someone who's
a UCLA alumni and he's giving me the
wrong era you you had a wold hazard and
Gail Goodrich played on that for it yeah
and then you had Kareem when he was luau
saying door with Lucius Allen right sure
and Michael did you ever work with Mike
Warren and Mike Warren no I never work
with Mike Warren
no little Hill Street Blues there ya
know they you in fact when we started
saying elsewhere the Hill Street Blues
was the day were the big boys on the on
the lot they were there were a huge hit
they were in there right in the middle
of their or their big run I know you got
a run good luck to your Cowboys even if
they don't make oh that's all right
that's okay I stick with my team anyway
I stick with my team right anyway that's
the way to do don't be afraid I'm a fan
to the end Cowboys
Emma good luck with the movie Denzel
good to talk to you again okay Bank
that's a Denzel Washington the new movie
is Roman J Israel Esquire for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]